um have you seen the video chris whitty
i'm sure you have um being
um assaulted uh by some
jobs last night um what do you think
should happen to them
and do you think that he should have
some form of protection because he
obviously
is dividing opinion this is the the
videos we're talking to you what do you
think
i think this scene is absolutely
appalling
and i'm sure all your viewers and the
general public
will absolutely condemn the behavior of
these jobs
chris whitley has done a fantastic job
uh
throughout the pandemic in advising the
government of the necessary measures
to keep uh our nhs uh
safe to save lives and he has you know
been a very effective
uh chief medical officer during that
that period and those scenes should not
have happened this is now a matter of
police investigation
and i hope the whole weight of the law
will will come down on
on people that engage in that kind of
behavior
should he uh be afforded some sort of
close protection
well that is a matter for uh for the
security services and
plan for chris whitty but those scenes
should never have occurred in our
society
absolutely wrong people whatever role
they have in government should be able
to
walk on the street walk through the park
unaccosted by
that kind of behavior it should not
happen in a in a free law abiding
society like ours